here's the story from the Associated
Press RFK Jr's independent run for
president draws GOP criticism and
Silence from National Democrats this I
find fascinating Republicans attacked
RFK Jr on Monday as the longtime
Environmental Lawyer blah blah blah now
threatening to take votes from former
president Donald Trump I believe this is
propaganda and a lie the Republican
National Committee in Trump's campaign
both took aim at Kennedy's liberal
background while National Democrats
stayed silent as Kennedy insisted in a
speech in Philadelphia quote voters
should not be by anyone who pretends to
have conservative values said Trump
spokesperson Steven Chung in a statement
he labeled Kennedy's campaign nothing
more than a vanity project for a liberal
Kennedy looking to cash in on his
family's name it's really funny because
um Democrats are hurt by this not not
Donald Trump I don't know if y'all
watched his speech where he talked about
finally the United States can recognize
indigenous people's day and stand up you
know blah blah blah left woke talking
point and said he wants to have a new
Declaration of Independence Independence
from the corporations that are doing all
these things and I'm like I don't see
this guy pulling any Trump voters he
might uh the crowd look to be more
liberal leaning and cheering for him
saying indigenous people's day I think
this Narrative of criticism from the GOP
is because they're trying to keep
Democrats unified and they want RFK to
be seen as Trump the way they stop RFK
from pulling votes from Democrats is by
convincing Democrats that RFK Jr is a
trump supporter or a trump in in some
way yeah and Trump and teed himself up
to have this moment in his speech where
he could have potentially really courted
Trump voters and then he Let It Go I
mean he did say a lot of really
interesting stuff along the way and I
thought it was perfectly fine uh he said
at one point you know his his big tenant
was uh we need to give up our addiction
to picking sides and I thought that was
a great great sentiment right so many
people don't want to hear anything they
know they're supposed to fall under a
certain label or side of a certain party
so they just continue to agree with it
no matter what he was saying uh for
example over the past six months I've
really started to listen to different
people people and I've gone to the
border and I've talked to border patrol
agents and migrants and people in the
community and I've really started to
think rethink my position on this and
then he moved on he didn't say so I
would commit to building the wall so I
would commit to ending Birthright
citizenship he didn't take any strong
Republican talking points he just
continued to say I'm I'm I'm I'm
flirting with the idea of per perhaps
being more uh serious about B border
control if he really wanted to court
Trump voters he would have taken a
strong stance on the board during the
speech uh you know I think that there
are a lot of Democrats who are unhappy
with Biden he does not pull well what is
it 60% think he's too old and so even
though I think it's like 68 it's some
ridiculous M so ultimately RFK is just
needing to be different than Biden and
he is going to do that obviously I mean
other than our scenario where he you
know collaps on stage and Newsome takes
over we know the DNC would never let RFK
be the front runner and so the
independent is the best way he can court
court voters at all like Ross perau what
do you think about him James I like RFK
I think he's run a great campaign
especially by saying he's going to uh
focus on the Deep State he's he's his
whole c campaign has been about the Deep
state is unaccountable to the American
people and my number one priority is
going to be fixing these government
agencies like HHS that destroyed the
country in 2020 so I think his campaign
has been great he may be playing to get
more Democrat votes now but I do think
the effect would be to take more
Republicans or at least right leaning
independence why would they vote for why
would a right-leaning independent vote
for Kennedy because they see all his
appearances on all these shows which are
overwhelmingly right-leaning and he's
he's talking to he's he's speaking to um
I think he's speaking to right leaning
voters he's antix he his whole thing is
opposing The coid Tyranny uh opposing
the Deep State and the leftwing media
hasn't given given him any Oxygen
whereas the right-wing media has been
giving him all his oxygen but but there
are many people on the left who hated
the lockdowns as well yeah true you
think as many I don't think as many
you're just sure but like I I don't see
that as being strong enough if if you
come out in your announcement speech
celebrating indigenous people's day I'm
not sure the anti-woke post Liberals are
going to be like that's my guy I saw
that and I cringed are you just saying
more also anti-un to capture like the
right-leaning Centrist because that's
the media he's in so that's who's
getting the eyeballs that's like those
are the people that happen to be seeing
him exactly I think that's what's
fueling his campaign or the right
leaning Centrist kind of the The Joe
Rogan listener crowd is what's fueling
rfk's campaign and the Republican
nominee if Trump wants to win in 2024
the key to Victory is to get that crowd
see I I can see where you're coming from
but he has RFK has Stead gained among
Democrats I mean he came out at like
what 5% he's almost up to 20%
favorability among Democrats now so as
much as maybe there are a couple people
who are excited about him who are sort
of moderate to you know almost
independent Republicans will say uh I
think there are more people who are
discontented in his base that he will to
pull away the numbers aren't
proportional I think it will hurt
Democrats more than I hope you guys are
right and it'll be interesting to see
what voters RFK targets now and if he
shifts the style of his campaign like
you just said Tim where maybe this is
more a leftward shift he's but that's
always been his campaign like it's been
conservatives that have been hooting and
hollering because they like what he said
about Co but they're ignoring everything
else that he said I mean and and a lot
of never would have voted a lot of
Libertarians have come out and been like
the dude is anti-gun he's like a liberal
who just his only position that aligns
with conservatives is that he didn't
like the co lockdown but he's also been
very critical of woke culture cancel
culture and the far-left and I think the
Republicans like him for that reason too
he's kind of this symbol of you know I'm
a non-woke liberal and Republicans love
to jump on that I just think that there
are lots of moderates who lean left
socially uh that also feel that way I
think we don't give enough credit the
fact that the DNC and the Biden
Administration have to court the middle
ground when they have positioned Kennedy
J no more and more towards the left uh I
think that he just needs to be not
establishment to a Biden DNC I think
that the Republicans have enough on the
field where it's unlikely that they
you'll see tons of Republicans flocking
to RFK cuz you know he ultimately is an
environmentalist lawyer I mean he's not
someone that is going to capture people
on their base I think what I find most
interesting about his shift towards uh
and being an independent candidate is
what he said which was that you know it
is painful for me to leave the party
that my family's political Legacy comes
from but I think it's so often that we
see the media obviously for for in my
opinion biased reasons focusing on
fractures within the Republican party
that they over they gloss over uh the
splintering that is going on among
Democrats and that's real it's
documented even if the mainstream media
AP News doesn't want to talk about it
and Cornell West who is more leftwing is
now also going to run as independent MH
so that's definitely taking votes away
from the Democrat according to ipsos in
a three-way race with RFK J's an
independent you have Biden getting 31
Trump getting 33 and RFK Jr getting 14
without RFK Jr it's a statistical tie
between Biden and Trump so ipsos data
from October 3rd to the 4th shows that
RFK Jr hurts the
Democrats so and this is what I this
this is what I thought if you take a
look at the graph you can actually see
that there is only tiny red sliver that
jumps to RFK but a larger portion of the
Democrats why Trump's supporters will
crawl overo broken glass to vote for him
Democrat voters think Joe Biden's too
old and don't like him they just don't
like
Trump and I mean I was looking at a poll
that came out of New Hampshire a couple
weeks ago you know they'll say who you
planning on voting for and they'll say
who's your second choice candidate and
it's not like Republicans are saying
well if it's if it's not my number one
choice you know disantis Trump whoever
it is I'm going to switch to RFK they're
going to pick another Republican they're
more likely to whereas Democrats are not
particularly happy with Biden already
and so if they're presented an
alternative it's more likely that
they'll pick it yeah like Viv I think
he's a much more favorable candidate to
a republican mindset than to Republican
but not to Democrat whereas RFK is you
know at least Baseline more Republic
especially to that moderate class that I
think the DNC really overlooks I mean
they trample on them all the time good
point I'm excited about it guys I love
when we have a third party candidate I
mean I will say I listen to this whole
speech um because that's what I do for
my job and uh I like that he talked
about he had this line saying you know
there have been independent candidates
in the past but this time it's going to
be different because you're going to win
and I don't think that's necessary neily
true but I do think that it's nice to
see someone who is representing people
who are frustrated with the party system
Teddy Roosevelt won third party yeah he
did take a look at this Kennedy family
members call RFK Jr's independent bid
dangerous to our country to be fair they
were doing that before they really don't
like him Christmas and Thanksgiving are
would be super awkward for the Kennedy
family this year yep they strip boats
away from can you imagine like having
Thanksgiving with your family and you're
a former Governor your brother is a
senator your other brother's running for
president and you're just like you know
you shouldn't be running for president
like well I'm going to it's like guys no
politics at the table Yeah Yeah they he
was saying his dad would have them all
talk politics Bobby or like I think his
grandpa would have his dad and his uncle
John and and I mean his speech he's
named dropping everybody because they
really did have such a Dynasty uh in his
life I mean it's not a joke I just can't
imagine you know working out like hey
you're not invited to Thanksgiving this
year because you're running for
president as a third party candidate did
they're like cool I didn't want to go
anyways thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net